Disney has actually admitted that the
movies they are producing the politics
contained do not align with the public
in an SEC filing they're telling their
investors our bottom line is at risk
because of the political nature of the
content we produce ladies and gentlemen
I want you to Revel in the victories of
watching this company get well go broke
and there's there's so much more to this
because uh uh joining us tonight we've
got Jeremy boring the daily wire just
put out a trailer for their new film
lady Ballers and it's fascinating to see
the success the rising growth of those
who oppose the wokeness and the weird
culty stuff in media and the failures at
the exact same time but we have a really
great example of this because it's not
just lady Ballers the daily wire
announces Snow White what happens what a
week later snow white from Disney which
got rid of the dwarves and is going with
the politically correct companions is
sheld they're pushing it way back and
they release a new image with CGI
dwarves to try and bring back the
original Snow White now that is Victory
so we're going to be talking a lot about
that plus we got some crazy political
stuff to get to eventually Chicago is
building two migrant camps this it this
it's insane clearing the way building
brick and mortar and tent cities for
non-citizens at the same time we're
seeing Democrats turning on Joe Biden
and Black and Hispanic voters are
shifting for Trump why I think in big
cities people are fed up with what's
going on with immigration so we'll talk
about that before we get started head
over to cast brew.com if you want to buy
the best cup of coffee you've ever had
get our Appalachian nights while you
still can we got whole bean we've got
ground we've got K Cups everybody seems
to love Appalachian Knights the most
rise with Roberto Jr is our light roast
it was it was very popular for a while
but if you support our efforts in
building this coffee shop and hopefully
once it's done we'll have hundreds of
locations in the next few years if you
want to see physical spaces where we can
play our content push our cultural
values retain our cultural values go to
cast brew.com and pick up a nice bag of
coffee today but also head over to
timcast.net
and hang out with like-minded
individuals so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends as I mentioned we've
got Jeremy boring of the daily wire
hanging out man good to be back
absolutely by back what's going on by
back I mean back in the United States
because I've spent the last uh six
months overseas making our pin dragon
cycle series that we've been working on
and you know it's been fun I've been in
the two most conservative two of the
three most conservative countries in
Europe Hungary and Italy and it's been
nice to see you people taking a
different approach to the problems of
our time I mean in particular Hungary
you know we're going to get to this
migrant thing with
Chicago hungary's just taken a no policy
to the migration question yeah I think
Poland has Poland as well so so the pen
Dragon thing I mean you guys that's a
series that's going to be seven episodes
debuting in 2024 wow so you've got that
you've got snow white you've got lady
Ballers of course I'm I'm sure there's a
bunch of other movies happening too that
no one knows about just yet yeah you
know we're uh as with Lady Ballers we've
got all kinds of things we don't tell
people one of the things people have
said to me all day today in fact one of
the people here at your place said how
did we not know about this I well we
went out of our way to make sure no one
knew about it in particular with Lady
Ballers we knew that if people knew
about it there was a good chance they
would find a way to stop us yeah very
interesting the whole time we're were
making the the film we were pseudonyms
and we called it coach miracle and all
of the written materials during the
production you just you know everybody's
out to stop the kind of work that we're
doing the kind of work that you're doing
so it it's it's you know what's
fascinating to me is that we get hit up
oh you know hey Jeremy would love to
come by we're like we want to have
Jeremy on the show uh we get hit up we
see the trailer lady Ballers and the day
you come is the day we get the breaking
news that Disney has admitted their
politics are failing them and I'm like
what perfect timing what absolutely
perfect timing it couldn't have worked
out much better right on we also have uh
Shane Cashman hanging out hey it's good
to be here happy to be here with you
Jeremy uh I WR for scanner.com and today
I published I think one of the most
important stories I'll probably ever
publish and it's about my weekend in
Ohio catching uh depraved demonic men
who sought to harm children with Alex
Rosen so you could check that out at uh
cnr.com once this episode is over thank
you yeah I tweeted that one out and uh I
just want to
say what I'm hearing from this story
that you've wrote written I've got
people messaging me saying dude this is
the best thing Shane has ever written
this is the most important thing and uh
I'm going to put my girlfriend on the
spot but we had to do like basic
analysis mhm the legal groundwork be
like okay here's the story and I got to
put her on the spot I walk in and I
don't she's crying and I'm like oh no
like something something happened I'm
kind of worried like why is she crying I
ask her if something's wrong she's like
no no no nothing's wrong nothing's wrong
and I'm like you're crying and she's
like I'm just reading Shane's article
and I was like oh my God after being
with the these demons for a few hours
and watching them say these things I I
cried watching them get cuffed cuz
you're just like it's like a release
after holding a face yeah I'm I'm hoping
that we could do a culture War episode
with you guys breaking all stff down I
would love it right on we got Libby
hanging out hey I'm hanging out I'm
Libby Emmons I'm the editor-in chief
with the post millennial and human
events.com glad to be here I haven't
read Shane's story yet but I hear it's
not bedtime reading so it's not it's not
it's it's tough It's a tough read but
it's important especially for parents to
know about with how vulnerable children
are on the internet yeah oh yeah and of
course sir just pressing the buttons yes
I am indeed here uh I'm ready to get
into it when you guys are let's let's
jump into this first story I you'll love
to see it from the Daily Mail woke
Disney admits misalignment between its
movies and what viewers want is harming
its bottom line after Progressive Snow
White reboot was pushed back for huge
overhaul I just I love the uh Financial
legal academic way of saying get woke go
broke yeah exactly we're
misaligned okay we have we have a phrase
for that here's the here's the gist of
it Disney has warned its investors of
the company's products and political
views may not align with what viewers
want and risk harming its bottom line in
a public Financial filing for the fiscal
quarter ending in September the
corporation acknowledged the risks in it
is taking relating to misalignment with
public and consumer tastes and
preferences for entertainment that's
amazing Disney has struggled as of late
to successfully pitch its costly films
to audiences losing a reported $1
billion on its last four high-profile
releases and uh I don't know if I
actually have uh yes I do have it pulled
up of course Disney's wish over
Thanksgiving weekend was another major
box office bomb and I think everybody
knows that movie is basically communist
right is that is that the general idea
are are you familiar with it Jeremy yeah
basically if there really was a God and
if he was any good he'd give us all
everything we want yeah but only in this
movie it's a white man who has the power
to Grant everything you want and refuses
and God he's a white dude he's a white
dude all right yeah it's a documentary
that's what it is a documentary
yeah so uh the the the the big news here
is they pushed back Snow White which
which shows not only are they admitting
to their
investors what we are doing is failing
they're taking corrective measures well
obviously the entire sort of Team
reality right marshaled a lot of
strength against well first with Bud
Light which I think is the greatest
boycott that we've ever seen uh in the
history of the right I mean we've never
been very good at that sort of taking
economic action punitive economic action
against anyone and after Dylan M they
you know they laid the Bud Light low but
now with Disney you saw the entire
rightwing really come out against them
and and daily wire you I'm proud to say
we took direct action and on the 100th
anniversary of Disney back on October
16th we announced the launch of our kids
platform bent key which is of all the
things we've ever built it's the thing
I'm I'm the most proud of we've we've
got 18 series on there four of them
original two of those chip Chilla are
first animated series and a wonderful
day with Mabel mlay I think are both
genuinely wonderful shows I'm very proud
to have uh played a role in bringing
them to life but we also announced that
we were going to make our own liveaction
adaptation of the Grim's fairy tale Snow
White and we were doing that in
particular because Rachel Zigler had
been the the Disney's new Snow White
have been so outspokenly
against Snow White the the film that
made Disney uh into the PowerHouse that
it is the 1937 animated film and she
said things like you know we're not
going to make make a movie like that
that movie had all kinds of problems you
know it had we're not going to make a
movie where the where the prince saves
the princess or any of this stuff what's
beautiful about that well what's awful
about it obviously is that she's saying
that the actual company for whom she
works a company with the most brand
loyalty of any company maybe in all of
history is somehow poorly founded
somehow had bad values and she's she's
far far better of a person than Walt
Disney was but what's beautiful now is
if you look at what Disney's going to do
with the film you know you said it
almost a you know Le than two weeks
later they they completely changed
course on their adaptation they are now
going to make a more faithful adaptation
and Rachel Zigler has to actually be in
the movie that she hates yes I I'm I'm
just imagining this this this when when
you're talking about this you're making
the Snow White I'm imagining that you're
driving this little buggy Behind These
semis that are gold is pouring off the
back and you're just picking it up and
like well whatever I might as well take
this oh they threw that out I'll take
this one too if they want to abandon
their most valuable IP and the things
that made them valuable I see in in so
many ways with uh like Jeremy's razor
for instance and Jeremy's chocolate
you're like well if you don't want it I
guess I'll take it yeah and now here
here's the daily wire ex exploding in in
in popularity because they're just
giving away this this value abandoning
it I mean I'm just a lowly I'm just a
lowly shampoo Mogul uh but I came by it
honest you know they if they don't want
the business to your point we're going
to make the business and and someone
asked me you know what what you do if
Disney manages to course correct here
first of all I don't think they can I
don't think that Disney I think they
know that something is a Miss I don't
think that they can identify the
difference between the parts of their
views that are so radical that the
public is rejecting them and the parts
of their views that aren't because they
live in a bubble within a bubble within
a bubble within a bubble people who've
worked for Disney uh have have told us
you know Disney has basically fired
everyone over the last 5 to seven years
who didn't tow that party line there's
no one left over there who would know
how to know how to do this if if they
were paid to but if they do manage to
course correct and if it cost me my
business I'll be like Elliot NES at the
end of uh The Untouchables I'll go have
a drink like what we won we won there it
would be far better for our culture it'd
be far better for Western Civilization
for Disney to become Disney again than
it would be for bentkey to spend the
next 100 years becoming Disney yeah yeah
you know the the way I see it is if I
woke up tomorrow and Disney was making
good familyfriendly content crime was
going way down the Democrats apologized
to Trump all of these things turned
around I I wouldn't know what to even do
I'd probably just sitting here talking
about UFOs or something and then I'd go
skateboarding and I'd be like I don't
need to do anything well those those
would be good shows too I would just I
would just sit at home with my thousands
and thousands and thousands of unsold
bottles of shampoo you do I would smell
great and have nothing to do I I feel
like yeah I you know the way way you
describe it is I i' probably much rather
have one solved these problems and then
retire off into the sunset and relax and
hang out get the get get a get a nice uh
Brick Oven grow some some burgers and
hang out with your friends and have a
beer but instead it's I wake up every
day and I am deeply concerned about
what's going to happen to this country
should we decide to walk away from the
culture War can I take a minute to talk
about Mary Poppins my favorite movie of
all time and something I wanted my
children to see one of the first movies
I saw uh and and how Disney now is the
product or the victim of rotten
creativity they've killed Ingenuity and
I think of what Walt did with with Mary
Poppins and the way he built the
animatronic birds and all these
beautiful things and the the meaning of
that first movie uh the original one is
about a guy who loses his job he's
having a hard time at home the the kids
are missing his dad then he got to bring
the family together through the beauty
of imagination and then and then after
all that he gets his job back right in
the new Mary Poppins that they remade or
it's like the second one it was my first
hint at Disney inverting those uh those
like meanings that are deep important to
me cuz I went to go see it without my
kids cuz I want to check it out first I
also love Mary Poppins because it is
it's crazy he didn't want to cry in
front of them I I didn't want to I cried
cuz it was so bad because they inverted
the meaning in the end in the end um the
guy gets the father gets his job back
he's happy and then finds in uh value in
imagination with his children that's
totally different which is completely
opposite of how it should be so that was
for me when I first started to realize
this is just rotten from the flo it is
Disney okay so I someone need I don't
know if you guys can fact check me and
check this out real time what uh the
when was the sale of Marvel to Disney
not that long ago right right it was was
it a few years it was in 2009 2009 is
something it happened y okay they they
bought Marvel for 4 million four billion
billion yeah sorry so wow then my then
my point was incorrect so I'll I'll I'll
set the one aside when I look at don't
let that stop you yeah well no no I was
going to make a point but I wanted to
make sure I was correct on my timeline
but I believe my timeline was wrong my
point I was going to make was where
where Disney is now with the Marvel
movies versus where they were with the
original Marvel movies right so the the
comparison I like to make often is
Captain America versus Captain Marvel
and why Captain Marvel bombs I mean the
first one I think did did decent and
then the last one was their worst ever
and why Captain America helped create
the MCU and this big movie empire
Captain America is a scrawny weak man
who desperately wants to fight for his
country so much so that he's trying to
lie to trick his way into the army MH
and then they have that scene where it's
Jack Nicholson's character oh no no it's
Tommy Lee not Jack Nicholson he's like I
want I don't want this scrawny guy I
want strong guys and he throws the fake
grenade and then it's the scrawny weak
Steve Rogers who jumps on the grenade to
save everybody else amazing scene what
is what is the ending of Captain Marvel
she was a woman who always had the power
but a man was keeping her down and kept
telling her to check her emotions it's
it's a caricature of what feminists
think being a woman is well that's what
happened in Snow White as well and you
had Rachel Ziegler talking repeatedly
about how the new story was going to be
about how Snow White became a powerful
figure just like her father always
wanted and I remember she said that and
I was like oh we're going to cover this
for post millennial let me dig back and
see what happened that's not in the
Grims fairy tale it's not in the
original Snow White Fair Brave and true
I think is what she said but she also
was talking the father and doing all
this stuff and the father doesn't appear
anywhere um but the other thing too is
that basically what Disney did was give
Snow White the wicked Queen's plot the
wicked Queen is the one who goes after
power she's the one who is driven by
avarice and jealousy and they gave that
to Snow White they made two villains in
that story they obliterated the heroin
and they told little girls love and
kindness and caring for other people
that's not what you should strive after
what you should strive after is to be
you know a Evil Queen
a girl boss a girl boss and everybody
knows that after we see them all on Tik
Tok those girl bosses they're miserable
also Beauty let's don't leave out Beauty
Snow White is fundamentally about beauty
and one of the things that's challenging
you know one of the things Zigler said
is you know it's not 1939
anymore and it's true Snow White wasn't
written in 1939 it's an Ancient Ancient
fairy tale it was preserved by the
brothers Grim but it probably goes back
hundreds of years even before the Grim
writing and what is it about what is the
sort of Timeless truth that allowed that
story to be older than our country much
much older than our country and and I I
think that what the fairy tale is
actually about is something that we it's
so foreign to us because we live in a
world where we can't talk about reality
at all and we haven't been able to talk
about reality
forever but there is an in in the
original writing it's not even a
stepmother it's actually her mother oh
wow and even the Grim version changed
that between between their original
publication and their later Publications
because it just felt too harsh but that
is but the the ancient veryy tale is the
mother and what the story is about is
the very common phenomenon that every
parent feels that over time your
children replace you and so the mother
gained notoriety or or attention or
security through her beauty and now her
daughter possesses more Beauty than she
and you know if you have a son you know
I don't but if you're the father of a
son it's a very common thing that people
don't talk much about when when your son
brings home the beautiful girl for prom
when he's 17 you know the father feels
some pride sure but he he also feels
some despair because it until now he's
been the one that women look to and now
the sun is and this is a it's a common
tragedy in life but it's but it's a
beautiful tragedy that over time our
children replace Us in an our Generation
where we live now we won't even have
kids for fear of missing out on any
piece of Life the idea that we could be
replaced by our kids that part of our
job is to take all of our not values
although that too but our value and
impart that value into the future by
creating replacements for ourselves
that's what Snow White is about I just
got to say I don't have kids but to
anybody who has that
feeling when when when your son finally
beats you at basketball or football MH
that should be one of the greatest
moments of your life absolutely that is
you winning that is you winning right
now and when you see your kids succeed
that is you succeeding your whole
mission the other thing too that happens
when you have kids at a certain point in
your life there's more life behind you
than there is ahead of you and you can
get lost in memories and looking back
but if you have a child then you can see
so far into the future it's absolutely
spectacular you can see you can think
about their future and their children's
future you know my son is already tired
of me saying don't forget to give Mommy
some grandbabies you
know I got got to pull this one up let's
let's go in depth on the on the snow
white thing so this is a story from
earlier in the Year Snow White and the
Seven politically correct
Companions and uh uh I think it's fair
to say so so let's let's go through the
timeline here's a photo uh exclusive
pictures of of Snow White's Seven
Companions uh one is a little person
because I guess dwarf is offensive even
though dwarf was the mythical dwarfs who
are made from Stone crafted from the mud
of mountains or whatever they decided
that was an insult towards little people
but uh this I think is is specifically
because when they announced they're
making the movie Peter Dinklage
complained yeah that's right they
probably behind the scenes were like
okay if we do this are we going to get
yelled at okay let's not do this so they
released this photo yeah the most famous
dwarf actor says that it's insulting to
hire dwarf actors he's the only one who
wants to have a job he doesn't want
anyone else so I want to make sure
everybody sees this timeline from the
daily wire on October 16th Daily wire
announces live action Snow White and the
evil queen Queen starring YouTube
sensation Brett Cooper the bombshell
announcement comes alongside the release
of the company's kids streaming at
bentkey and then we have this October
28th from insidethemagic.net Disney
whitewashes Snow White after diverse
casting backlash CGI caught by fans so
only about a couple weeks later they
released this photo of Rachel zagler
wearing the traditional dress surrounded
by CGI white dwarf
so white I think that was you guys I
think you you said this earlier yeah I I
think that we certainly played an
outside role obviously there was a lot
of backlash Beyond just us but we took
very direct action we put our money on
the line to directly challenge them and
you know two weeks is the speed of light
for a corporation the size of of Disney
and you can just look at this CGI photo
that they released It's So Below the
quality standards of of Disney who are
the greatest animators you know in all
of human history they obviously rushed
this thing out now this is Crisis
management and I think that we if we
weren't the entire crisis I think that
we were the most acute part of the
crisis for them at that time I I think
it's the announcement of your Snow White
that made them say oh no they so uh the
previous segment we're talking about how
Disney is admitting to their
shareholders this is from the end of
their September end of their was it uh
quarter quarter 3 and uh in September so
this is a month before you guys
announced they are outright telling
their their shareholders we are losing
money because of a misalignment
misalignment between the the content and
the culture we make and what the public
actually wants that's in sep the end of
September they know this yeah in October
you announce and I guarantee there's
someone at Disney being like what
happens when Disney Snow White bombs and
daily wies Snow White breaks records
that is going to be the Disney brand
falling into the toilet they're going to
try taking their writers because Disney
has no substance or stories with any
meaning at all and that's why people
aren't connect with it they're going to
screw this up too oh yeah obviously well
what they'll do with this I I think and
I think that the the photo sort of
speaks to this is it will just be a beat
for beat retelling of the 37 film right
C can they screw that up sure but good
good thing they have going for them it
will be hard to screw up because they
have one of the great animated films of
all time to model it after that's true
but I think they're going to screw it up
yeah yeah I think they'll slip things in
there so if you take a look at the
Marvels why it so uh if you the Marvel
movies plan after Robert Dany Jr was
brie Larsson would take over as as the
the central figure with Captain Marvel
replacing Iron Man as the centerpiece
but she was so despised in the press for
being this woke angry leftist and and
and to be fair it's not just wokeness
she really did not mesh well with the
other actors zegler is doing the same
thing she is coming out snoody snide
condescending arrogant and overly woke I
think that's going to cause them
problems for this film I think they're
going to you're right they're going to
do a shot for shot remake but they're
going to have PR problems because of her
well I think they've got another problem
you look at this photo of her with the
CGI dwarves and the question that I have
is is she even in this photo did they do
a photo shoot they she is a living
breathing human and sure there's a lot
at stake at pissing off at pissing off
Disney but how are they going to get her
to keep her mouth shut about this they
haven't been able to get her to shut her
mouth up until now they they've replaced
the faces of actors before on haven't
they when when someone like messes up
and like we got to just replace that
person maybe they'll do that to her cuz
look they kind of like surrounded her
with the patriarchy in this picture they
just took a bunch of white doors like
you know what this is what you get think
there's Sneezy patriarch and grumpy
patriarch but think about it maybe it's
possible this actress never actually
believed any of the garbage and was just
saying this because her agent and Disney
were like this is this is what we're
going for and so she said okay I'll say
these things on the carpet I think the
likelihood is she's woke well I'll go a
little a little further and just say I
don't know how she 20 years old 22 years
old or something she's just a kid I I
I've said a lot of bad things about her
lately because she put herself in a
position where I need to publicly oppose
her but at the end of the day on a human
level I have a lot of sympathy for dumb
kids being dumb kids for sure you know
but I I just got to say I I got to push
back we we got to stop calling 22y old's
children no you know I actually
appreciate you calling me out on this I
I went on at length about this uh
publicly not two weeks ago that we fanal
adults by calling them kids right she is
young and she's particularly young in
the way that our culture measures age
today and so I have some sympathy for
her but you're right she is no kid she's
an adult she has agency she's
responsible for her actions and I I take
that rebuke yeah and I think because I I
was talking about this earlier too we
need to REM like the the Millennials are
our Lost Generation I'm sorry guys I
know everyone's like but Tim your
Millennial I know but uh I talked about
the survey last week Boomers Gen X and
genz all say they will be comfortable
with 120,000 a year Millennials the one
generation they say they need half a
million half a million a year yes yes
and there's some weird thing that
happens and I know she's what 22 so
she's actually gen Z I believe then
right it's not it's not absolute it's
not one for one but we need to start
telling people like you need to be an
adult you need to start taking care of
yourself but that being said imagine she
is genuinely woke genuinely opposes
patriarch and all that and then one day
like you said is she even in this photo
they they rushed out CGI they they
cranked this photo out I imag I imagine
she gets blindsided by this oh the
oldest whitest Bob
Iger right mhm just takes away her
little dream that's right yes and and
she's contractually obligated I wonder
if she got an angry phone call what is
this I don't want to be a part of this
it's insulting and ableist to wasn't it
not just her saying this wasn't it uh
isn't Wonder Woman was wasn't she also
saying she was but if you watch the
clips with g and I realize I'm being
very soft here on on all of these guys
which isn't my usual reputation but if
you watch galado do standing beside her
saying things like we're not going to be
saved by The Prince and you can kind of
tell that galado is trying to be
generous to this young woman standing
next to her she's also trying to like be
one of the girls and be on the team you
know she's trying to to have friends y
you know I just I I I cannot stand how
feminists insult women and I'll tell you
why it's not just feminists I understand
that back in the day men would laugh at
oh my wife goes shopping oh gez and I'm
just like there's this article that was
put out today that claims women are
better Hunters than men and that this
univers yeah right Jeremy's face is like
are you kidding me yeah they said women
actually can do endurance better than
males can which means pre in prehistoric
days they were hunting more than we
realize and we're better and I'm like no
just stop shut up women showing and
Gathering and protecting and raising
children is Honorable and extremely
important but in this malthusian
political era where they despise the
creation of More Humans they have to
insult women for being caregivers the
greatest technological advancement since
fire is not the printing press it's not
the Internet it's not electricity it's
the sanitary napkin and the thing that
no one really can contemplate in today's
day even women today are a woman today
is so disconnected from Every Woman Who
Lived before the 20th century that she
can't really even imagine what life was
like I know that women weren't the great
hunters in days of your because they
were pregnant all the time right or had
tiny babies that they were nursing all
the time or couldn't leave the cave for
one out of every handful of weeks
because well and that still happens in
Nepal I was going to say you can look at
India and Nepal today uh and and it's
still happening you have to look for it
but it's still happening and the life of
a woman in
preindustrial times for this particular
reason is so different than we can
possibly imagine it just it's just we we
live on the other side of of sanitary
napkins and birth control pills and we
and we think that we know what women
have been like throughout all of history
that's absurd so they they they make
this narrative Snow White is insulting
when in fact it is beautiful of course
it's beautiful yeah and and all of these
other about women and their desires and
what they want I was uh reading that why
do women like shopping because it's the
modern equivalent of gathering and I'm
like I think it's because they like
pretty things well that's why I go
shopping but why why do you like pretty
things colorful things in the wild
berries and fruits the reason why uh
women can see more more shades of
different colors the reason why women
are more likely to be tetrachromats
seeing with uh The Wider spectrum is
because uh the idea being and I'm not
saying it's 100% correct but it's
plausible women are gathering collecting
foraging extremely important for human
civilization and men were hunting mhm so
men have spatial reasoning and like they
can map things better but women create
human beings oh yeah they do these
studies all the time you like put men
and women in a circle in a room and over
time all of the women begin to lean in
and all of the men begin to lean out
looking for Predators it's just oh wow
we're just wired Camille paga talks
about that with the uh women in Italy
and she talks about how um absurd it is
now that women and Men Are Meant to do
the exact same type of job and she talks
about in the old villages the women
would gather around you know the well or
the pump and this is this comes up in
new hampson as well and the growth of
the soil and all of that stuff um you
know women create these communities and
it really is kind of tragic that these
communities have fallen apart because
that's where you would learn um things
about raising your children that's where
you would learn things about preparing
food and making clothing and all of
these kinds of things and now it's just
gone yeah building Community is
something that women are uniquely good
at and you know so I'll self-promote for
a minute we we've just released the
trailer yesterday for this new film that
we're doing called lady Ballers and I
give a speech in the film about the
difference between men and women and I
you the whole film you're seeing men
just completely dominate women sports
well let should we let's let's let's
pull it up well let's we have this uh I
I chose the best source I could out.com
and they've titled it this trailer for a
quote comedy film about trans athletes
is the worst thing we've ever
seen Jeremy what do you have to say for
yourself well I'm looking up the article
now so it says um I I chose this one
because of course we have to go for the
criticism it's a well-known fact that
right-wingers cannot make good art and
don't have a sense of humor at the same
time I just wanted to pause uh y'all
call Joe Rogan right-wing and he is one
of the top comedians of all time so nice
try but let's read they say the daily
wies reminding us all with the new
preview fort's first featur length
company comedy lady ballers in a world
where women's sports is being
transformed the daily wire calls foul
with the most triggering comedy of the
year so of course uh they're they're
absolutely triggered by it but in real
news we have this story from daily wire
so you just went on Patrick B David's
show and the headline is Jeremy boring
says theaters won't touch lady Ballers
because Hollywood has made
transgenderism its religion but uh the
just just to get the whole thing going
you put out a new trailer it's about
guys who find a path towards making
money by identifying as women but why
don't why don't you take it away yeah I
mean it's all in the name right lady
Ballers uh here here I going to read
this from out though because it it sets
it up well it says the premise of Lady
Ballers seems to be that any out of
shape 50-year-old white man is by nature
of being a man a better athlete than any
woman could ever hope to be you see
women are just factually bad at sports
this movie States first of all what
nobody involved in the movie is uh 50
second of all we do not state that women
are factually bad at sports we state
that women are fact worse at sports than
men it's science it is it is TR it is
truly science don't you trust the
science men sometimes men are stronger
and faster than women and this is why
full stop the left can't they can't even
acknowledge that basic fundamental
reality since they can't acknowledge
that basic fundamental reality they
can't understand why we have any of the
opinions that we have they're not
allowed to know that it's true and so
they don't know that it's true then I
would I would ask why then do they have
testosterone limits why do they have
that standard for so the reality is
because they do know they're just lying
that's right well and we see it across
the country we see in Maine and in
California just recently there were male
athletes competing in women's um you
know CrossCountry events and they were
taking home all the awards for sure sure
and that's going to keep happening the
average high school boy involved in
track runs faster than world record
Olympian women wow yeah we saw the
women's US soccer team was beaten by a
like high school team yeah when when I
was talking about this article that said
Prehistoric Women were better hunters
and it's the argument was that because
of and it's it's it's all nonsense It's
like because because of um women have
have they carry more body fat they have
more energy for endurance that that
actually creates drag and more weight
and so I was like I can debunk this very
simply I think actually your debunking
was better they were pregnant they were
nursing children so they're not out
hunting but there I just said okay I
pulled up marathon time and distance and
sure enough men beat women in all of it
well let me just here's a little uh
mental exercise for you a riddle if you
will why do we even have women Sports
because sometimes people wear
dresses answered a riddle with a riddle
we have women's sports because if you
didn't have women's sports women would
never win at any sports the whole
purpose of creating women's sports a as
a category well so that there was a
place where women could Excel well and
that's what Title 9 was all about right
and now that's been completely destroyed
and the left leftwing the leftist
argument is we have women's sports
because sometimes people wear dresses MH
you know but that's seriously it and and
that's looks like the premise of your
movie where these guys are like wait I
can identify as a woman play the team
and then identifies as a man later yep
gender fluid the story is actually based
sometimes you wear a dress sometimes you
don't Germany's movie is based on zubie
the yeah exactly well there was a thing
recently there was a a a a
trans um identified male murdered a
trans identified female in Norway just
gave me a headache I it really happens
but the Norwegian the Norwegian um
papers reported this as woman kills man
but really it's just your typical man
kills woman just like we see all over
the place know this why I can't stand I
think I'm not sure Fox News does this I
think they may use preferred pronouns or
or presumed pronouns I think is the
important distinction presumed pronouns
are when these media organizations will
use atypical pronouns without without
actually knowing preferred pronouns so
for instance uh the daily male does this
all the time if there is a person that
that is presumed to be trans they will
use the inverse pronouns even though
they don't actually know if that person
uses the pronouns they're trying to
because of like UK hate speech laws or
something like when I was still a
professor teaching journalism fiction
all that stuff the style guide changed
and they wanted black to be capitalized
but white to be lowercase so there's
these little Insidious ways that they're
putting they're changing literal
language I refuse to do that oh I'll
never do that it's ridiculous it's
really stupid it's insane yeah it's bad
enough that we have to capitalize
Hispanic which means person from South
America who speaks Spanish y does it I
don't even know if it means from South
America does it well it doesn't mean
Spain it no it means speak Spanish
doesn't it I thought it meant I thought
it just meant Central South America but
not then I guess Brazil is out of that
huh Brazil is not in that and that's
what sort of shows the whole lie right
there that makes it just absurd here's a
line from this out article about us it
says you love this
article there's here's the thing if
you're going to win an election if if if
like you're way up in the polls you
always watch MSNBC right it's much it's
much more fun to read what they say
about us than what we say about us but I
like this it's not clear if director and
star Jeremy boring has ever written or
acted before I mean it is clear if you
could Google in the time you did this or
if he has ever met a woman in real life
and the answer is I guess I don't know
based on whatever descriptor they might
use for the how how do they Define it
how do they Define it holy moly I love
it this is fun you should frame this so
so I just looked it up and uh Hispanic
is a Spanish speaking person living in
the US living in the US comma especially
one of Latin American descent so you're
you're you're correct what I'm close the
the general concept is if you if you
like Jeremy if you learn Spanish right
now you're Hispanic yeah that's weird I
don't quite understand but uh I guess
realistically uh you know there's also a
joke in the trailer about um trans age
yeah where but this is trans age was
attempted in a lawsuit um I think it was
a professor who did it as a an attack on
that the concept of identity it may may
have been in Europe as well saying I
actually identify as 30 when they were
59 or something and the cour there's
that British guy who wears diapers and
says he identifies as Stefani like a
5-year-old girl or something is he the
guy who films himself in public I don't
know but he was adopted by um other
grown-ups who let him play with their
daughter yeah which is
nasty absolutely not I'd love to see you
Shane one second listen in New York New
York
City gender identity is a protected
category which includes gender
expression and gender expression is
legally defined as
self-expression so I I I I went over
this in 2018 quite literally you the
clothing you wear the name you use you
cannot be discriminated against so that
this this means everything you could you
could show up in stilts and clown makeup
and they can't tell you're not allowed
to wear it it's it's a it's against my
gender identity I wear these clothes it
would be discriminatory now New York is
saying I don't know if you saw this
weight and height you can't discriminate
on the basis of weight M no
discrimination against fat people so but
what if someone can't fit so think about
this someone goes to a movie theater in
New York and there's 300 lb and they say
I can't fit in these chairs well now
you're discriminating because you're not
providing an accommodation to large
people didn't the firemen in New York
change the weight requirements years
back too yeah and cops all kinds of
stuff maybe not just in New York but I
was in New York at the time when I saw
it it's uh yeah it's it's insane yeah I
don't get it but here's the thing we
have to mock these ideas I agree what
what brought us to make lady Ballers is
one understanding the power of mockery
and and two honestly something that Joe
Rogan said about a year ago a little
over a year ago he had he had a guest on
his show and he said you know nobody he
talks about this a lot no Hollywood
won't make comedies anymore and it's
absolutely true Barack Obama destroyed
rock and roll and he destroyed comedy
and he destroyed America other than
those three things great
president he also killed American
citizens without charge a trial Let's uh
nice but he he made it impossible for us
to tell jokes yeah and that's why from
the '90s and the early 2000s you had
great comedies being produced by
Hollywood you haven't had one since
Tropic Thunder because you're not
allowed to make any jokes so yeah what
is the go ahead are there any recent
comedies I mean no they're not funny you
can't make a comedy no really and so I
wanted to use comedy in and mockery
Rogan talks about it all the time and he
said to a guest a little over a year ago
he said nobody can make a comedy now he
said if if anybody was going to do it it
have to be one of these conservative
streamers like the daily wire and when
he said it yes people send you that what
Joe Rogan mentioned the daily wire you
know they send it to you but it really
struck me and I thought this this is
kind of a a challenge and a
responsibility if it is true that only
the daily wire could do this then it
stands to reason that the daily wire
must do it if we actually believe the
things that we report to believe and we
actually are uniquely capable of
challenging this new status quo wherein
you're not allowed to make fun of
anything including the most absurd
things that are happening in our culture
y then then we just have to do it just
just anything I mean uh uh over the
holiday weekend I'm I'm hanging out with
Sheamus and my girlfriend and uh it's
after Thanksgiving so you know Sheamus
is from Chicago as well and we were we
were all making jokes about our
backgrounds the the the the the issue of
family family history comes up and then
we make joke Sheamus started Sheamus
makes jokes about being Irish and being
the Potato Man and stuff and we play
along with it and he laughs and then we
make jokes about Korea and we're all
laughing at each other and the left
would call them racist jokes I would
just call it me and my friends having a
good time with each other and laughing
well I'll tell you this in the 90s we
could still make those jokes they were
good jokes they were good jokes and
there was far far less racial division
in the country I remember yeah that was
very distinct and come coming up into
the 2000s and you're looking back at the
90s going we were colorblind we were
friends with everybody none of it was a
very big deal and I remember um
distinctly probably something like 2012
running into an old friend of mine from
college a black woman we were hanging
out at this bar in Brooklyn and we were
just chatting and she said something
that was totally different than what she
thought when we were in college she said
that when people see her she wants them
to see her Blackness first she wants
them to see her race first and I was
like but but why like that's not what I
see when I look at you and the switch
was that now it was racist to not notice
race yeah that's right yes whereas
previously none of us had cared at all
cult
indoctrination from similar backgrounds
you know similar schools all of that we
went to the same you know private
college everything watching watching
them destroy comedy though with their
ideology was so hurtful for me because
comedy is one of my favorite art forms
you know for two reasons it brings
people together we can make fun of each
other I love kill Tony it's one of my
favorite shows they roast the heck out
of each
they're brutal I love that I do that
with my friends but also like Mel Brooks
used to say comedy mocking people could
destroy your enemies right and that's
what he would do in his look at Rickles
like suddenly you're friends with
everybody exactly but let's let's let's
uh actually I'd like to ask you directly
about the film and what can you say
about it I mean I don't I don't know if
you want to reveal the plot or break
down the the general premise what's
going on yeah I'll say more about it
than is is present in the trailer which
is that of
course we start our journey by by trying
to become successful by trying to get
back in the game where where this you
know I'm a coach and I get together my
former state- winning boys basketball
team and say hey if we call ourselves
women we can get back into the game
pretty soon we realized we're being
driven to this by my new girlfriend who
is a a journalist and and she has very
ulterior motives you know but she she's
excited for it well she's driving it
she's like here's what we're going to do
think of the sponsorships think of the
fame she and she gets the exclusive and
and I'm learning I'm I'm I'm hearing all
these ideas about the trans movement
from my 8-year-old daughter cuz she goes
to public school and then I pick her up
from school every day and she tells me
things like gender fluidity and
pansexuality and all this stuff and she
educates you she educates me yeah as
they do as you do y but pretty soon we
we realized that it's not just
basketball I me we my guys could
literally win at every sport I mean
there's a really funny line where where
I'm like hey to one of the guys like hey
you want to hang out later and he's like
nah I got to learn how to do a backhand
so I can qualify for the women's Olympic
tenness
although In fairness we don't use the
term Olympic because you may not know
this you do not have free speech in this
country where the word Olympic is
concerned really is that's why I say
Global games yeah it's the global games
you cannot use the term Olympics by law
in this country an actual Statute in the
United States legal uh legal code
why I'm running for president yeah got
to run executive order wow when did you
realize that in the process though like
very late very late in the process yeah
unfortunately and anyway all of this to
say and this brings it full circle what
to what got me on the topic of promoting
my own beautiful movie is that toward
the end of the movie I have to make a
case for why even though men are better
at virtually everything now that's a
joke but everything in this case is
sports you why would someone who is a
female want to continue being a female
would they not aspire to be a man and it
was challenging to come up with a list
of things to say in a serious moment of
the film that women are good at that
people wouldn't roll their eyes at and
then I because the things that women are
good at are things that our culture has
decided don't have high value and this
real decided that they don't have high
value which is insane this is when I
realized that not for the first time but
had it really reinforced that the war on
men is a war on women
essentially essentially what the culture
hates the most is women not men I agree
it's women that's correct I I i' I've
said this for a while feminism is
destroying femininity it is telling
women to to adopt masculine features
masculine roles this is why men are bad
so be just like them it's it's it's
insane we we when you look at the
numbers transgender youth I think one
study said 85% were female to it's
mostly women cut yeah it's mostly young
girls getting their breast cut off and
wanting to be men and what they don't
realize is it doesn't matter what they
do they're never going to be men they're
still going to be short they're never
going to like look like men they're
never going to have that power and
they're never going to have that respect
and it doesn't matter even if you put
like Jace on the name tag you know it's
it's never going to be you when when I
was a kid my mom was in a she was a
corporate attorney and um she was always
she was often talking about how she was
the only woman in the boardroom and she
was like trying to dress and be more
masculine and stuff and she and the
women of her generation I remember her
friends and you know my uh mother-in-law
and everything would talk about how they
didn't want to cook and they didn't want
to clean and they didn't want to do any
of these things and I had a stepmother
who all she wanted to do was be a mom
she wanted to be a stay-at-home mom she
wasn't able to have children of her own
and so she looked at these other women
she looked at my mom and everything and
was just horrified that they hated
everything that she wanted you know they
gave up everything that she wanted most
jeez it's the the attack on men is like
first of all let's get rid of fatherhood
role models in the house the nuclear
family Terri and then if they attack the
women it's basically they can prevent
that from ever even happening right no
babies no household you just grow up and
be miserable and then you die yes but
the the misery is coming
everyone Teri yeah of the misery single
M like look too many Millennial men and
women are single and they're having
families and yes uh uh I always preface
this with I am doing my family stuff
calm down everybody because I know full
well the the idea of when Chelsea
Handler said she wakes up at 600 in the
morning smokes she does drugs then
masturbates and goes back to bed and I'm
like that's wonderful I'm sure she's
loving it I'm not sure she's loving it
no I think it's it's it's a dopamine hit
it's triggering it's it's dopamine but
what's going to happen what's going to
happen when she's 70 in the hospital
after suffering a cerebral hemorrhage
and she's or she or some kind of disease
and she's dying and she's by herself and
the doctor says press the button if you
need us and walks out of the room and
then she's just just staring at a cold
wall with with nothing to show for it
with no one around her no no future
ahead of her my grandfather was buried
today he died uh Sunday
night and it's this amazing kind of
rebuke of parts of my life I me parts of
my life he really inspired he was an
entrepreneur late in life uh very late
in life found success and and inspired
entrepreneurism in in his sons and
Grandsons in particular but other parts
of my life are very distinct from his
you know he had seven children he has 20
two grandchildren great grandchildren
you know he he died basically two months
shy of becoming a great
great-grandfather
and his legacy long after the memory of
him is gone me one generation from now
two generations from now nobody will
remember his name right do you know your
great great grandfather's name and if
even if you do do you know your great
great great-grandfather's name I mean
history will forget my
grandfather but a thousand years from
now the impact of his life will still
exist through the children that he's
pushed into the future and the values
that he's pushed into those children
that get pushed into the future
generation after generation and somehow
we came of age at a time when we when
our culture ascribed not only no value
to that but negative value to it yeah
one of the what if we deprive people I I
bring this up a lot but one of those
Emanuel Brothers Rob emanuel's brother
talked about why we don't need old
people anymore old people should stop
caring for themselves and basically just
die not basically they said die you know
and tell people all the time knowing
your grandparents is the best that was
little has inspired me in this life more
than my grandfather Yeah uh he was a
true uh inspiration to me in so many
ways as a family man as a business guy
and and a creative and uh a lot of
people don't have that attachment to
their grandfathers or or any grandparent
and that is uh truly sad to have like
that uh to be divorced from history like
that because they can teach you so much
from the the decades that they Acquired
and all the stuff you know all the
information they got um so yeah now we
have a world where they're not having
kids to become the role models and they
don't have any connection to the past so
they'll be these very decrepit
meaningless vessels humans but I do
think more and more here we are sitting
here talking about the success daily
wire's having I mean forcing Disney to
course correct on Snow White is
hilarious and if anything that's a
tremendous Victory but let's see your
Snow White do better because you know
the these companies need to learn a real
lesson y but we're watching all these
tremendous victories we're learning now
that um there's a huge swing towards
Trump whether you're for Trump or
anybody else Biden is losing support
tremendously oh I mean SNL mocked him
for the first time so The Jig Is up what
did they do Jig Is up knocked him huh
yeah they're in trouble I didn't see it
who played
Biden do you know the names of anybody
on I don't know anybody on there anymore
as I said that I was Saturday
night here here's what I'm saying Big B
yeah these here's the scary future that
I see conservatives are having kids
Y and Liberals are rewarding their kids
and even to some some degrees even some
of their kids are being sterilized it's
I don't act like it's all of their kids
it's a few thousand I think and it's
into tens of thousands that are getting
these treatments but what is the future
in 20 years going to be these 30
Millennials right now what's the average
Millennial age like 36 or 37 right yeah
my brothers are that age they're nearing
their 60s they're going to be nearing
their 60s in 20 years they're going to
be getting close to retirement oh who
knows by then retirement age might be
like 77 or something especially
considering the economy now well
actually I take that back dep
considering this backlash by then
retirement age might go down and but
imagine these people when they're
retired no families no savings what do
they do the inverse is that
conservatives have kids 20 years from
now there is going to be two to one
conservative to Liberal kids now people
may change their values so some of the
kids of par of conservative parents May
adopt liberal ideologies but it's also
true that the inverse could happen
especially with the push back in schools
I think it's fair to say based on the
fact that liberals overwhelmingly abort
relative to conservatives and
conservatives 20 years ago were already
having more kids you are going to have
woke feminist Millennial retirees males
and females single childless begging for
handouts from a government that will not
give it because conservatives win the
voting block we talk a lot about like
the par parallel economy right but I
really think it's going to be not
parallel realities but fractured
realities where we're going to inhabit
the real world where we're talking about
before we went live about taking the
physical space back you know and they're
going to inhabit the digital space
that's where all their identities are
mostly uploaded they care more about the
digital world than they do the physical
world here's an interesting wrinkle on
that is AI oh yeah that the digital
world is becoming more and more
artificial over time and I think that
there's going to be a reaction to that
where people want tangible physical
events and engagements yeah you
conservatives love to catastrophize
right oh AI is the end of the world is
the end of this well of course it's a
massive it's another one of those
massive technological changes and the
world will change around it but there
are good things that come out of these
advances and one of the good things I
suspect out of the out of this new sort
of artificial digital age will be a
return to actual human connection I I
only when I sit in a room with you and
look you in the eye and talk to you do I
know that you're a real person it's like
looking at people go back and getting
into vinyl again after being so I mean
kids kids still go ride bikes totally
you know my my fear is that the other
half of that will be people embracing
the AI world so much that they want to
marry the AI and they will have people
literally fighting to
marri that of course that will happen
all the bad things will happen yes but
this is but good things will also I want
to catastrophize
JY this is the Divergence you mentioned
because uh so we just bought we're
building we're building freed dastan and
it's been in construction for a minute
but uh uh awesome news I mean the
drywall is going up in the in the in the
lower Studios uh yeah we've got the
designs for the indoor out outdoor skat
Park portion so it is moving and we're
thinking maybe by February you know it
could even be sooner than that but uh uh
we just bought a sound system from an
antique store from the 90s with cassette
vinyl amfm radio and a CD player and the
rule is when you're playing music in the
park it has to be a vinyl played from
start to finish you will turn the vinyl
on you will go and you'll flip it over
you finish that album before you can
play anything else why I cannot stand
the digital playlist reality I can't
stand that whenever you open the app
it's one song from one band and it's 700
bands with one song and so I said no no
no I don't want that anymore I want the
core original give me an album from one
band we're listening imagine imagine
that there are adults alive today who
have never listen to the bside of ABY
Road they don't know that that's a thing
they may have heard every song off of it
but that is not the experience of
listening you'd be shocked when I travel
with my records how many people are like
what the hell are these they look them
like they're like these foreign like
they pull it out of they literally see
them open the box and then take it out
and they're like looking like I've never
seen this in my life I'm like dude it's
a record like you don't know what that
is really yeah but you be you'd be
amazed people literally have never seen
it before I want to expand out on what
Jeremy was saying too cuz I I agree I
love the mixtape but I I this would be
nice if if the positivity does grow out
of this and uh people Embrace family
again you know that would be an amazing
uh transition out of this hell Escape
that we've been in and it's possible cuz
I I'm in a community now where I'm
surrounded by people who are beautiful
families and when I was in New York I
was not surrounded by that at all it was
uh completely defunct and anti- family I
I I do just have to mention this that we
pulled up an article previously that you
were on Patrick Bet David's podcast in
Miami and now you're here in effectively
West Virginia and I'm like man yeah this
guy works you were just in Where Were
You you were in uh Bud where you I've
been overseas this is my first time in
the States since July 10th wow and I
scouted for a month in Europe before
that so by Christmas it will be true
that I spent the majority of
2023 overseas wow other than family is
there stuff that you realize you were
missing from Mexican food true that's a
big one I missed that here we don't Taco
Bell yeah we don't we don't have great
Mexican food in Nashville either but we
have some Mexican whenever I go to Texas
I'm always like we need tacos yes time
for tacos but to be fair the American
versions of it are nowhere near what
Mexican food actually is oh yeah but
it's ours you know I know I like the
American versions when I say Mexican
food I mean TexMex yeah I want I want
like the American version of Chinese
food I C cucumbers I want like general
chicken and some you know low M that's
well let's let's get a little bit more
political in this uh so we talked lot
about culture but we have this story
from the Chicago Tribune construction on
Brighton Park migrant Camp to begin with
State involvement this week despite
aldermanic opposition can I just point
out really quickly that beautiful word
Alder manic man I have not made a movie
about this just I want to be clear about
the Alder manics so aldermen are the are
like the mayors of a neighborhood so I
love the Alder manic opposition it's a
great word but uh here's what's
happening the people of Chicago are
Furious they do not want illegal
immigrants in their City same is true
for New York Democrats are suffering
because of this but it doesn't matter
why several reasons there's one base
reason and the simple reason is there
are men who are willing to take blood
Money stripped from your pockets in your
bank accounts to build facilities for
non-citizens and they don't care they
don't care about your community they
don't care about you they don't care
about what happens to the city when the
government comes to these men in these
construction vehicles and says here's
the project they say okay I'll take
money no matter where it comes from so
the people of Chicago in opposition to
this are having their tax dollars taken
and these men are willing to accept it
that's the first problem MH second
problem is politically they do not care
what the people of the city actually
want they will build facilities for
non-citizens and this is going to be I
think politically apocalyptic for
Democrats because now we're seeing
Donald Trump is improving among Black
and Hispanic voters and I think this is
partly due to you get these videos of
Chicago where it's black community
members screaming get these illegal
immigrants out of our neighborhoods they
don't care but but let me just stress
also the sheer shock when I saw a video
on Twitter X where they're like we are
building a camp on the south side of
Chicago for illegal immigrants we're not
talking like a small Park we're talking
a massive multi-acre facility they're
talking brick and mortar structures yeah
what do they mean by Camp they just mean
a building no they're building multiple
structures yeah well this is like when
you hear a refugee camp inside the Gaza
Strip and then it turns out it's a city
with skyscrapers right interesting word
C Camp is a yeah well one of them is a
tent city so I guess you can call it but
when you have multiple Acres I don't
know if if it has PL if it has Plumbing
though it's a at a minimum it's a
migrant clamp well we there was a thing
in New York just recently where they put
up a whole bunch of dormitories at Floyd
Bennett Field which is a you know an old
Airfield and uh migrants were warning
each other not to go there they were
like oh no it's not acceptable and one
woman said we did not go because we
already know the situation over there we
saw people returned with children they
say it's not suitable there there is
nothing there not even a television no
TV no TV oh my
goodness I think it's human right
violation human un Charter viol we got
to what's going on no TVs we should
protest I have to say I have loved
seeing you know black people in Chicago
and New York just be like no we're not
doing this it makes me think that maybe
we can REM yeah ER Adams has been really
working on this and he has been styed at
every step of the way and now they're
attacking him now they're attacking him
they're they're destroying the schools
you know that we're already faltering um
but I have loved seeing black Americans
stand up and be like no we don't want
this it makes me think that perhaps all
of us Americans or as original Americans
can get together and be like we're
Americans we love our country we don't
want it to be over run race is not the
thing that should divide us here you
know it should be the Border absolutely
culture is real
and the great lie of the 20th century is
that culture is not real that all
cultures are equal that you can
relativism that you can yeah you can
basically Shuffle the deck of all humans
across the entire globe and still wind
up with the exact same soup and you
can't you know France is a place for
French people and England is a place for
the English and America's a place for
Americans and you could say well there's
no such thing as Americans and that's
true but there's no such thing as
English either like at a certain point
cultures come and they go and America
yes is a nation that was founded largely
by immigrants but those immigrants did
come together and create a culture I'm
not anti-immigration but I'm anti any
kind of immigration that radically and
rapidly changes the makeup of the
culture of a country because you can't
have a nation if you don't have culture
you have to have common culture well
this this is an important uh Point uh
the Constitution the Bill of Rights are
what 1789 we had free speech yeah they'd
still arrest you for obscenity laws if
you spoke in certain ways like George
Carlin famously even in in the 70s you
get arrested for it it is the culture
that we have today this is why I say
we're winning a lot of people don't want
to accept it but you can look at the
tangible realities of the budlight
boycot I want to say right now a huge
fan of budlight and a big supporter of
theirs after they sponsored UFC we were
very critical of them but then seeing
what Sean Strickland said did you see
this one no so so Bud Light SP but uh
but let me just wrap that point up we're
winning by the way and this is the point
we are winning Sean Strickland said he
was so happy that budlight sponsored UFC
and we're like no oh come on Bud Light
they're crooked and then he's like now
they're putting money behind every word
I say and I went oh okay I agree I agree
there's no backing down for Bud Light
now MMA fighters are notoriously based
and he said some stuff that I can't say
on YouTube and the UFC paid for it I'm
sorry sorry budlight paid for it so now
I'm like okay I'll take it there you go
he's fixing the brand by going a little
far in the other direction well you've
seen their advertising it's sort of like
it's like 80s spectacular advertising
all of a sudden I do make a Bud Light
joke in lady Ballers and maybe I should
reevaluate it although it's too late now
well but we were wondering when's
Jeremy's beer I mean you've got
everything else yeah I will uh here's
some breaking news oh for our timcast
fans there will not be a Jeremy's beer
when you when you watch lady Ballers
this weekend you will notice that there
are cans all throughout the movie that
say Jeremy's pilzner on them they're
very welld designed and that's because I
thought that by the time the movie came
out I would release my P
ER but it turns out canned beverages are
very difficult and alcohol is even more
difficult still and I've I've made the
decision that and I don't drink so
somehow in this combination of of
challenges I thought maybe just let that
one slide but as what I want what I
wanted to say about winning is when you
look at freedom of speech despite the
government manipulations with and
collusion with big Tech we are I believe
we are winning we're winning culturally
we're not winning in in the realm of
policy yet which matters right but I
agree that there's I agree that there's
a shift culturally in our favor right
we've begun forwarding the line yes is
the way I describe it we may not have
the whole battlefield but also the
Second Amendment i i i i there I I do
not believe there is we have the whole
Battlefield I mean or I should say we
have we have more than 26 State States
uh constitutional carry or permitless
concealed carry I think Florida and so
that is the majority of the battlefield
in terms of Statewide now they're trying
still to ban things but they're losing
there was a poll NBC News the poll that
showed young voters are leaning Trump by
like two uh it's a fourpoint margin also
show that the majority of people whether
you're democrat or republican have guns
in their household yeah so I think we're
winning constitutionally now I'd love to
see uh uh there there's a lot of stuff
going to the Supreme Court let's see you
know what we get through there's um I I
don't know if I should say too much but
one of our guests was talking about
another case on uh uh the NFA which is
is being is going to is going to be uh
challenged all the way to the Supreme
Court we'll see how it plays out but I
think I think we are winning so I'm
having a good time there's bad stuff
going on we call it the bad stuff all
the time but uh the night is always
darkest before the dawn however there is
a light at the end of the tunnel I'm
seeing a lot of people on both sides
understand that the border is a mess you
know like when I saw Eric Adams talking
about I was completely shocked I've been
to the Border a few times reporting on
it this year it is a complete tragedy
completely open the amount of fentanyl
coming through is is absurd and and
undocumented people who just get sent
wherever they want to go it's like soft
TSA down there I me it's so bad I am
livid at the story of the construction
happening in Chicago and I all of my
anger is at the workingclass
construction guys 100% did you see um
they they should have said I ain't
touching that money instead they were
just like yeah I'll take money to
disrupt and destroy this community it's
it's it's disgusting there should be a
concept of a country over company the
founding fathers were wealthy men they
were very wealthy and they had every
reason to say to anyone with patriotic
sentiments shut your mouths you're going
to spoil my fun I've got I've got land
I've got buildings I've got properties
I've got companies and I got a family to
protect I ain't signing that Declaration
of Independence they did the opposite
they said the king will kill me he will
take my family he will beat my children
he will steal from me and I will be left
destitute but it must be done it's not
rare in these big cities for these
companies to have the unions who are
with the government tight tight you know
so that's why maybe this is not as
surprising yeah that's right did you see
the The Washington Post came out in
favor of border control they said in a
yeah in an editorial board they said um
Democrats might Flinch at the
proposition but the Republican idea that
it should be tougher for Asylum Seekers
to enter the United States makes some
sense wow some just some yeah he said
they said um hundreds of thousands of
people who reach the southern border
every year hope to leave a dismal
existence behind but most are not in
persecution in fear for life or limb
they seek Asylum because the US Asylum
system is the only door available to
knock
on that's in the Washington Post the the
border patrol that I talk to down there
all all different types of people are
like there's so many just men about our
age coming over they don't know where
they're from they're not like they're
from not all from Mexico they're from
China they're from Africa they're all
from all various places huras Ukraine
and and they do get a lot of people who
are repeat offenders as then they've
come been kicked out and they come back
back uh but they just got through
there's there's so many places where
there's a hole in the wall or or uh you
know these tribes have their land on the
border and they don't have a wall cuz
it's s Sovereign land so you just walk
to the wall and be like skir right
around and you're in and that's it uh so
it's great to see that I wonder what
they how they Define a border policy but
start in one of these stories uh it was
a story from ABC7 they interviewed a
Honduran Mig Grant who said I'm living
worse than I lived in Honduras it's very
cold I want to go home Venezuelans were
saying that in Chicago as well this is
typical someone some group is lying to
these people and telling them to come
and they arrive in freezing cities with
no resources and they're like I don't
understand they're like the streets are
paved with gold they get to San
Francisco and it's paved with poop I
mean literal poop literally these people
are told there are jobs and they're
they're they're like oh the United
States has opened the Border they're
saying come there's jobs for you and
they go oh okay they hop on these trains
They Ride thousands of miles and they
show up and they're like this is not
correct and the funny thing is even now
Democrats are are outraged over this but
you have Progressive leftists that are
still and the woke they're they're still
very much in that I mean AOC is pretty
mum on this one right she's the Trump
concentration camps person right she
will she will burn her political base if
she comes out and says no this is a good
thing now hold on she did remember when
initially when she said we're going to
get work permits for them housing for
them and people are screaming at her so
I think she know Hotel in New York the
Democrats are in trouble even the
progressive ones
she's such an opportunist I could see
her down the road probably soon from now
look what you said about Hamas yeah
Israel Palestine did you she this is
this is someone who has a root in in in
Progressive leftism before she's in
office the uh uh the activists were
operating under the assumption that she
was Pro Palestine her position now is we
need surgical strikes to assassinate
Hamas and I'm like someone knows who her
constituents do not like Hamas but her
woke Progressive fan base do mhm so she
she chooses the political mainstream
which is the only path towards I mean
look let's be let's be real she
represents the Bronx that's not really a
it's not that Progressive it's mostly
right Po and I think that the let's be
honest there's a 40% chance she's
president you think so you think oh yeah
AOC if the culture doesn't shift away
from that that's right it's possible
there there's a real path for AOC to be
president we like to make fun of her
because well for all the reasons there's
so many all reason that's why she says
these things that are surprising to us
sometimes CU she sees it it's all
politics she doesn't have any moral
center it's whatever's going to get her
to the White House but I I think you're
right 40% might be the right number uh
not greater than chance but significant
I I don't know that right now she has
the gravitas but she certainly could Oh
no you're saying down the line yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's going to be not 2024
yeah but that's what I mean I see her
running for sure she she has a like 40%
seems like the correct number there is a
possibility eight or 10 years she has
developed that that personal maybe Nikki
Haley will pick her as vice president oh
my
goodness perhaps well the rumor is she
wants to run for I don't know if this is
true she wants to be senator in New York
or something I think that is true I
think she wants to do that who would she
replace Schumer would she go after
Schumer's seat yeah apparently that's it
that's the one that's open to her it'll
it'll probably happen they're so crazy
up there I mean we got we felt sort of
good for getting Cuomo out I mean not
cuz he was me too I didn't think he
deserved that I thought he should have
been mass
murder remember when he released the
video of him kissing everybody he's like
I I do this to everybody so the response
was you admit to doing it more than we
thought right I mean the thing that's
how you push people out of that's how
you push people out of office in New
York you accuse them of random sexual
harassment crap from years ago and then
take their job and put in someone way
worse Kath H is a disaster yeah Eric
Adams with his like they're demanding 5
million from him what did he even do
nobody even knows it was from like 1993
oh yeah hok's hok's really really bad I
mean she was talking about having
disciples for the for the shot back in
the day uh now her whole thing of like
uh she's in it with Laticia James the
hate speech thing they're they're going
to monitor people's social media yeah
it's it's it's nuts but that's what they
but also I love New York it's my home
state and it's not all that bad it's the
city that ruins it for most of the the
dang place city is spectacular though
it's the greatest City on I love the
city let's talk about the potential path
towards uh uh 2024 going Democrat we
have the story is China's mystery
pneumonia sweeping Europe Netherlands
sees alarming surge in similar illness
among children as terrifying video shows
Hazmat clad workers in China
disinfecting schools I keep seeing
people say don't fall for it as we're
getting more and more data of a strange
respiratory illness well now they're
going to they're going to make sure that
children are a vector of it cuz last
time children were not a vector yeah can
you overlay pup Trump's poll num this
actually you know I think I think we
actually can do I have no we don't have
it right here oh wait wait hold on
Trump's poll lead expands with Biden
losing Black and Hispanic support well
you get the general idea but is it the
flu I mean they're calling it a
pneumonia yeah but it's also winter and
people get sick more in Winter I don't
know look I'm not a doctor talk to your
doctor I'm just saying surprise surprise
as we're entering an election year all
of a sudden we're getting this news
hopefully it goes nowhere but remain
Vigilant watch out for these attempts to
shock and scare you and create Panic so
that you vote for their their their
choice of
candidate yeah I think we have to
remember that it's also a lot of uh
anti-id stuff I heard somebody saying
that some of the video is lifted from
the from Co in the past so some of the
videos yeah some of the videos like
cleaning and disinfecting and stuff like
that was lifted from the past because
not a lot of media comes out of China
unless it comes out of the China Post
just like when CBS posted video of a
busy Hospital from New York but it was
ital numerous agencies did that for
months they kept showing the same thing
over and over again same thing man same
thing that's okay so so here's look I
often when I'm reading the news I can
imagine possible scenarios when it comes
to polling like you know Moody will come
out and say the economy is doing so
poorly Biden's going to lose by this
margin and I'm imagining what happens I
cannot visualize what happens with Joe
Biden oh no I mean he can't he can't be
the candidate they've got to get rid of
him but what do they do do they do they
act like he's going to be the nominee
and then abruptly at the convention just
announce Gavin Newsome well also we have
right now the the likely nominee from
both parties is be are beyond the
average life expectancy of an American
man I know I know it's it's just an
honest observation that you cannot know
what's going to happen I mean it's
always true that you can't know what but
especially now you can't know what's
going to happen in this election okay to
be fair to be fair Trump is almost at
the life expectancy which is I believe
79 yeah and Biden is is dropping though
the life expectancy for American men y i
I'm I'm not saying that means a whole
lot when he's a year and a half away
from the average expectancy but I can
picture Biden getting oh wait no I'm
sorry I'm sorry uh no Jeremy was correct
it went it went down MH it so the latest
it's like 73 I think is so the last time
we checked it was actually 70 78 79 and
uh the latest numbers are now 77.2 eight
so in fact you are correct sir Trump is
77 I can't imagine Biden in the white
house uh at all I still can't but I
wonder if it's going to be him bowing
out and they're going to play like this
Val
way of him leaving like oh it was a
noble thing to do he stepped down we're
going to get you know
the be heart attack or do they they play
The Tragedy card which is what a lot of
people in government love to do so it's
got It's got do a lot it's got to be a
heart attack or something yeah I don't
know or they just prop him up and keep
it going McConnell's still there I mean
he is old yeah but he can't win not no
but he's still there I mean you think
someone be like we got to get you you're
saying Joe Biden can't win Joe Biden
can't win no I don't think that's true
you think he I think he can win yeah
okay let me say this as of right now all
data indicates Biden will not win yep
there's a lot of reasons why he can win
I'm just saying I think that it has been
thus far it has been a great asset not a
liability that Joe Biden is nearly dead
he defeat he defeated Trump in 2020 by
being a corpse like that was actually
that was actually the the best
recommendation that you could make for
him totally yeah well that's what uh was
it Atlantic who wrote that I Stay Alive
Joe Biden all we need is your Corporal
form D that's one of my favorite Shane
Gillis jokes he says like that's what
Trump does he gets inside people's minds
but you can't get in a Joe's head's not
even there man that well so what's
what's the realistic scenario you think
Biden runs in whatever corpse-like
fashion which means not doing anything
but then people vote for him well one
thing you have to know about Democrats
historically in elections
is none of their internal rules actually
matter yeah so just as an example if if
you're a Democrat and you die after an
election is ostensibly
underway they just put your they just
let people vote for you and then put
your wife in and then they put your wife
in there's nothing legal about that
there's nothing no no per the bylaws
they just do it was was that in
Pennsylvania was that in Pennsylvania
where was that uh we we did cover this
yeah there was a a politician was
running he died just before election day
they said whatever and then his wife was
appointed to fill the role familiar yeah
something like that I think it was like
a senator or something like that how do
they just pass that how do they just say
that's okay well because because when uh
party rules well a a governor is appoint
Senator if there's a vacancy so like
when when Obama got elected and Illinois
had an open seat bovich famously said
I'm not giving this away this thing away
for free or whatever the quote was right
he went to jail for it pardoned by Trump
right well oh yeah that's right that's
right wow Illinois is one heck this is a
thing that keeps happening and but why
the wife like why would they just
default to the wife and not I think they
were hoping for widows who succeed their
husbands in Congress that happens a lot
oh yeah that's weird and there's
articles about this going back to 2014
what this is Lady Ballers too but but so
I I understand this but what's President
doct Joe Biden
right Jo bid what's the scenario then I
this is why this is my point I I I can
understand what you're saying the rules
don't matter but so what is the
realistic scenario that we witness in
2024 are we as political junkies going
to be watching like figuratively it's a
debate stage with with an empty space
and Trump yelling at the wind ai ai
Biden yeah no but I mean in the news
we're going to have Trump Trump trump is
it just going to be nothing about the
Democrats at all yeah they could run
everything in the way he Biden ran his
campaign that's essentially how that's
essentially was their strategy in 2020
stay Stayed in the basement quiet stay
in the
basement Studio they manipulate the
reality through corporate press a lot of
people buy into it and that's that if if
that's the case if you if you compare
the uh political polling average today
to 2020 it is completely inverted and
Trump is on a on a path towards major
victory I think this time is different
though because he's shown what he does
as the president he's shown like his
hand he doesn't have like the we don't
know what he's going to be like in the
we we really did if you look back into
his political history you knew what he
was going to be like but the average
person didn't know what Joe Biden was
going to be like as president I think
he's already shown what he's like the
NBC poll that we cited recent just a
moment ago shows that if the Democrats
have any other candidate Trump loses
it's one poll don't know if it's true
but they say if it's Trump V Biden Biden
loses if it's Trump versus any
Democratic candidate Trump loses people
love Nome I I don't do they really know
how they when I was in California at the
GOP debate that dude walked up into the
Reagan Library the GOP debate yeah uh
the second one and he he showed up and
people fawned over him Sean Hannity
practically made out with with Nu in
front of me I mean they were so smitten
with each other it was disgusting and um
I I talked to a lot of uh conservative
women who find Newsome Charming yeah
they know he's depraved nasty and gross
but there's something about him he's
like this poster boy for politics of
days old where he's got the hair and all
this stuff they find something Charming
I don't think they'd vote for him he's
like a lizard man he well I know he is I
saw him change out of that suit I feel
like he's Democrat Mitt Romney though
yeah I think he's Romney is more like a
Saltine though who's ineffective has a
passive actual depravity and a liar like
a big time liar I don't see how Nome
doesn't become president the guy terrifi
just think about his career path destroy
San Francisco become governor destroy
California president he steps into the
Wasteland of America destroy uh Middle
East and South America and the Korean
Peninsula and then become Supreme
Chancellor M there you go yeah something
like that he's got the look but you what
you say Romney's a Saltine yeah I think
so so like dry and UNP just nothing
about like what has he done that's I I
don't know about him as well as I know
Nome but he seems like he hasn't been as
effective in positive or negative ways
as well we got uh was it Newsome V de
santis on Thursday oh yeah when Romney
was in Massachusetts for a while right
was that where he was yeah uh so I don't
know I don't know how people thought of
him back then and people liked him for
to me uh he looks like he's just like
Obama and many ways you know the way he
talk no no no uh Romney the way Romney
talks now is is basically he's like
Obama you know they're they're they're
into war uh they're part of the uni
party and uh I'm tired of that and Nome
is the king of all that crap they all
they all look up to Nome yeah I I can
imagine the Democratic Convention
happens and they just say we all the
super delegates have teamed up to vote
for Nome your votes don't matter he
apologized for his covid ways that's
enough for them I don't think they' even
bring that up he you already apologized
they would blow right by it just I
mean who else they pick on the left do
you think Nome is is running 2024 you
think he's going to be the guy I mean we
all think he's secretly run well no one
will run against Biden it all comes down
to what happens with Biden but if Biden
is not running which I I think to be
clear Biden is currently running to be
president so something has to change
right then yeah I think nome's probably
the go-to guy I think they flirted with
the idea of it being Budaj for a while
that's just not going to happen oh gosh
no he's terrible he's terrible and he
took all that time off he's just a waste
I mean when I was in East Palestine
after the train exploded the way he
handled that whole situation those
people were Furious I mean Furious and
that's how a lot of America felt
watching him visit I'm putting in quotes
uh East Palestine it just is atrocious
but I don't know a lot of people can
agree how terrible nsum was in
California but they still there's a lot
of people who still love him you know
yep so I could see him but they Jeremy's
right there he's not going to go against
uh but right so is Biden how's Biden
going to be out well Biden has even said
Gavin Newsome could have my job
yeah recently well Kam nobody likes
kamla nobody liked comma when she was
running what was it she got like she had
3% of the vote before she dropped out of
the primary she was trash and everyone
know knows it she's also the one who is
essentially responsible in part for this
whole border thing she was supposed to
be in charge of it and her you know and
she was supposed to deal with the border
and her office was like nuh-uh no she
isn't that's nuh what border right we're
not supposed to do that we're supposed
to be dealing with the root causes of
migration which is violence against
lgbtq people in the northern triangle
countries let me uh I'm going to pull
this story from uh the New York Times
Are black voters leaving Democrats
behind they say polls suggest they might
be well we looked at an NBC poll that I
think showed Trump with 24% of the black
vote and if that's true according to to
the Wall Street Journal several years
ago they wrote an article in like 2018
that said that if Democrats can't
maintain uh 80% if Republicans ever get
more than 20 the Democrats are they
can't win at all so I'm not sure I
believe these things right there's been
a lot of conservative personalities who
said you are insane to think black
voters are are going to move towards
Trump in any way the New York Times asks
the question and then the New York Post
runs this story Trump poll uh lead uh
Trump polling lead expands with Biden
losing Black and Hispanic support so I'm
wondering if it's not so much that Trump
is gaining but that because Biden is
losing it it results in a vote vacuum
you don't need to vote for Trump if
you're not voting Trump is still going
to create a gap by
having people not vote for Joe Biden
right yeah I think that's happen people
are realizing I saw a lot of people this
weekend I forget what it was but people
realizing that they had life better
underneath the Trump underneath Trump
and they have under Biden simple as that
they say Biden's lead among Hispanic
voters is now 3% down from 14 in an
Emerson poll last November wow 11 points
shift they say Biden's lead lead among
African-Americans was still substantial
47 but down 15 points and then there was
that uh that poll in New York Biden is
up 10 points in a d plus 27 he's only up
10 wellow Trump's also New York you know
there's a lot of people in New York who
who still love Trump and who understood
Trump before a lot of the country did
cuz if you're from New York you know the
certain type of
this guy he's not all of these things
he's he's this big bombastic kid from
Queens he wasn't shocking to us no you
know when we saw him but for a lot of
the country it was like whoa what is
this the New York Times is saying
Trump's lead uh his support among black
voters is
22% so up several points they say in
2020 Biden defeated Trump by 4.5 in the
popular vote though he won by much
narrower margins in the swing states
that saw him uh now look I think it's
ultimately I wonder why we even talk
about this stuff a year out that's the
thing so much is going to change the uh
if for example Ronda santis wins in Iowa
which there's a very strong likelihood
that he will he's he's locked up 30,000
Precinct or uh and he's working real
hard chairs he's working real hard
y then from January 15th through super
Tuesday anything can happen just
anything can happen and particularly in
an election where going into the spring
all of Trump's legal problems catch up
with him yeah that's true and we I mean
so among the many things that can happen
we could be running someone from jail I
that is not that is not an impossible
scenario given how how upside down Topsy
Turvy the world is now uh and certainly
not constitutionally prohibited
either my view of this I I borrow this
from my friend Alan estan over at Prager
U uh he he points out that narrative is
an actual force in the universe sort of
like gravity it's not narrative isn't
something that we do it's something that
we observe and if you go by that theory
then at a minimum the story belongs to
Donald Trump it is Donald Trump's story
it doesn't mean he wins the election uh
but I don't think people are ready we
haven't gotten to the end of the Donald
Trump story yet and people want to know
what the end of the Donald Trump story
is more than they want to know what the
next story is so true I love narrative
can feel it it is a substance in the car
Carl Benjamin made this point to me he
did this is like a year and a half ago I
was saying I thought DeSantis was the
was the right choice um he had a better
temperament proven leadership not that
Trump you know didn't but Trump's
temperament wasn't there and then Carl
messaged me saying Trump's Arc is not
done Trump's story must be completed he
made a video about it and now things
have shifted so I you think even with
Trump's legal problems This lends itself
to Trump winning and or or at least very
well being the nominee and and making it
to November well whether he's the
nominee or not I think that maybe he
takes the entire Republican party down
like may maybe for example Ronda santis
wins Iowa he gets a big boost going into
South Carolina he somehow gets past
Nikki Haley there Ronda STIs becomes the
nominee Donald Trump splits the party
and says he he won't back Ronda santis
Donald Trump uh loses the election for
Republicans or the Santa somehow wins
and pardons Donald Trump and it's the
greatest what what ever it is it's like
whatever the craziest thing we can
imagine somehow the Donald Trump story
still hasn't ended and the most likely
outcome is the most uh entertaining is
that what Elon says yes most likely out
come is it's going to end with Trump
outside the White House jumping midair
then Freeze Frame we just back to normal
I mean fair point I mean but really if
you think about it Trump's story AR can
end in a lot of really crazy ways oh
yeah for sure they're not all good right
right like January 6 nobody saw coming
imagine January 6 time 10 with an angry
Donald Trump and some whatever hisory
Arc becomes now I guess the difference
there is Trump was actually president
when January six was going down he could
have done a lot of things he did not do
now he's not president there's a lot of
things he can't do and so this just
won't happen but weird things can happen
my my bigger concern is probably his
story could end rather
unceremoniously through health issues oh
yeah yeah I mean and in in in both the
uh uh uh external and internal cly
someone could hurt him mhm or he could
quite literally just at
77 you know be shuffled loose the Mortal
coil what I'm worried about is like
we've been witnessing absurdity like
exponentially grow every year over the
past few years what is next year's
October surprise going to be it's going
to be so terrifying and absurd you know
like or I'm also you know they've been
dropping these hints lately about the
internet apocalypse you know because
solar flares right right is that going
to happen like are we not going to be
able to talk and communicate anymore I
keep wondering about that and I'm like
you know we really should have kept up
with the United States Postal Service
you know I want to entertain that
possibility because just imagine this
scenario it's a week before the election
and solar flare internet is cut out
serly internet's gone and the only thing
available now is radio and terrestrial
television so we're radio and so what
happens is you've got no internet
industry is collapsed but you turn the
TV on and there's your good friend Wolf
Blitzer letting you know that Joe Biden
won trust him oh that's it well wouldn't
it be nice if we had paper ballots
before the solar flare takes out the
grid that would be so nice they had
paper ballots in Argentina we need to
push that how long did it take him to
count those votes two three months I
think it was just one I think it was
just the one day no one day impossible
understand one day I know I think they
were you know even
just just went they may try to turn off
the country and turn it back on again
internet goes down just in time for the
election and yeah nobody can communic no
organiz they did essentially do that in
2020 they basically shut down the world
and and then tried to turn it back on
again and we still W we've come nowhere
near the end of the consequences that's
crazy and back then as terrible as that
was we could still subvert their
narrative because we could communicate
through the internet they know now they
got to get rid of that so we can't
subvert them so we have to make ham
radios and homing Pig some way to
communicate Hami let's do it you take
our bank accounts andone Tim ham doesn't
sound very good I don't know that might
be well no we want we want ham internet
yeah I know so data transmission through
ham which is ridiculously slow Hamet I
like it you're you're better off just
talking yeah on the street go go outside
and Shout that's yeah but seriously imag
just actually imagine what it would be
like if it was three days before the
election and there's no internet at all
and we all are old enough to remember
life before the internet yeah there a
lot of young people who do not oh yeah
it's glorious in many ways you actually
it's kind of crazy to think about like a
like there's 20-year-olds who do not
know life without access to the internet
there are younger children man it's it's
2023 so a kid born in two in 200 let's
let's be realistic born in 200 2000 you
are not old enough to understand life
and cell phones and internet by the time
you seven or eight cell phones are
ubiquitous yep by the time you're 13
everyone's got one now you're 23 years
old you have never lived a moment
without instant access information cell
phone and there's never been a point at
which You've Lost That yeah you've gone
to dead zones you've been out at parties
in the desert where no connectivity but
you've never been in a city with no
internet right that's crazy that's where
that fracturing that we were talking
about earlier is going to take place you
know because those people at that age
they're their identity online means as
much of them as their identity out here
exact which isy sad but like what you
were saying earlier hopefully there's
some people who realize they we reject
that we want real life we want a family
we're going to go to the supermarket we
want to see necessary it's necessary to
um you know curate your online presence
because otherwise your online presence
is going to come back and get you fired
from your job yeah so you got to be
careful of it yeah yeah but I am seeing
I do think that more kids are kind of
like of the Gen Z and if I can use my
you know just this year teenage son as
an example they're much more interested
in being anonymous online they don't
want to put their names out they don't
even necessarily want to put their faces
out there you know they want to be in
person with their friends and they want
to have whatever the curated thing but
they don't put as much stock in their
identity online they use it they do a
lot of jokes just trolling just a lot of
that stuff isn't that what hok wants to
get rid of in her said my you know my
son I'm anti anonymity on the
internet to what degree because I think
it's it's appropriate for people to be
able to be anonymous uh for various
reasons but it's also I I think it's
weak for people too especially if you go
after people I don't think that
it's here's the
problem the problem is that anonymity on
the internet allows for the ghettoizing
of beliefs that are not approved by the
regime so a lot of people will say well
I have to be I have to be anonymous on
the internet because my boss finds out
that I've got these views they'll fire
me but you're only in the position where
your boss could fire you for finding out
about those views because you've allowed
those views to be completely get wise
through anonymity online if uh I
if 5 million people came out today and
said uh the
nword I'm not recommending it but no one
would ever get fired for saying the
nword again like they would be able to
you wouldn't be able to you would have
brought that to you would have brought
that to a conclusion that little
absurdity in our culture uh would be
brought to an end the ghettoizing of our
beliefs allows for the punishment of
anyone who steps outside of the ghetto
yeah so if they catch you saying what
you believe they can fire you but if we
all just had our names on it we're
saying the things that we believe and
you might
say that we would have more cultural
cohesion if we didn't have online n
andity to because the online anonymity
also allows us to become more
radicalized in ways that Pro left and
right in ways that probably aren't
ultimately good I I I agree but I think
it's a cultural issue that you can't
solve with policy you can't just be like
okay no one's allowed to be anonymous on
the internet we're going to we're going
to require this my view is you should
you if you want to be anonymous in your
writings and in your interactions you
can be but I think culturally we need to
say we don't interact with you know if
if you're if you're not a serious person
I can choose not to interact with you
and then some people will choose
whenever I've said publicly that I don't
I think online anonymity is bad one
thing that comes up a lot is what about
women you women violence against women
will increase because men will follow
them home and be able to get their home
address and all of this but again I
think that that's a kind of ghetto
mentality the truth is that most of the
horrible things that are said to women
online aren't said by people who put
their names on their accounts I think
just outside of that though I'm I'm more
worried about people wanting to express
themselves in any way jobs be damned you
know it's just like I want people to say
whatever they want however they want and
express themselves that way I personally
prefer a real face and a real name
that's what I always do but I also
understand there a lot of people not
just because their jobs maybe it's
family and I understand I I personally
think that's weak of them but it's it's
what they have to do and I agree with
him
if we can change the idea of it without
policy I'm that's I mean and there are a
lot of problems with trying to change it
at a policy level yeah for example the
first amendment I don't think that it is
impossible to make a First Amendment
compliant argument for why online am
anonymity isn't uh
isn't to to create policy that curtails
some some amount of online anonymity and
people will say uh the founding fathers
all wrote Under pseudonyms And yeah
writing under pseudonyms is very
important but I don't know that saying
to a woman uh I want to rape you and
murder you in her
DMS is exactly the same as as like The
Federalist Papers like there there is
there is a distinction in how online
anonymity Works compared to publishing
anonymity is is that is the violent type
I've got like death threats from
Anonymous people occasionally and it's
it's terrible but there's are people who
are using for various reasons but this
may we're talking specifically about
social media networks so you can still
publish an article online through a
publication anonymously and they can
choose to share it online through their
accounts oh yeah I'm all for that and
and additionally I want to point out too
whatever whatever it is we do need there
to be in most cases some kind of
identification why if Twitter chooses to
allow pornography they should also have
to screen for miners MH it I it is
unacceptable in my opinion that
YouTube's answer is uh we'll leave the
video up it's the parents issue I guess
and some things will flag as 18 and up
only and then you have to you have to
log in and that's it so a 13-year-old
kid makes a fake account says they're 18
and they can watch the graphic material
again if a kid walked into an adult
bookstore and the guy let him in that
guy would be arrested charged the
business would be shut down you it's
illegal to let children I do not accept
that X allows adult material and
children at the same time I that that
that is an absurdity to me how is that
how is that reality how did we as
Society just decide one day that we no
longer care to our children from adult
bookstores hold hold on when did it
become that you can you can forget going
to Pornhub you can Google almost
anything and get it in your results like
it'll actually come up in your results
you can accidentally do stuff I used to
I used to work with a company and they
were looking for fans and they were they
looked there's this company called Big
Ass Fans and uh they looked at they just
Googled it instead of going directly to
the website and one of my colleagues was
like uh by the way everybody don't just
Google that like you just want to put in
the right website yeah we're going to go
to super chats so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.net
carnivore says not first again
unfortunately you were first Shane H
Wilder says Tim great seeing you on pop
culture crisis 500 today although now
I'm going to have to make a meme video
on your reaction crisis parties and
hopefully drop it tomorrow pop culture
crisis uh had its 500th episode today
that's correct so that's absolutely
fantastic for those that are interested
in pop culture uh conversations so the
way I describe it is Tim cast is very
political and then we get into cultural
stuff like we did today but typically
political uh pop culture crisis is the
inverse it is pop culture and then gets
into the cultural uh elements and stuff
so we talked about uh AI girlfriends how
they uh eeve magazine put out an an
aggregate of all all of the different
ideal girlfriends they pulled like 2,000
people in each state and then took the
keywords and AI generated images of
women and it's really it's got
fascinating implications cuz like
California the ideal girlfriend is
ethnically ambiguous I'm well it makes
sense you've got a large black
population Hispanic Asian and white and
if you combine everything they want you
get someone who could be any one of them
so you know that's the kind of stories
we cover there uh they talk about other
stuff video games they're talking about
I guess GTA the new one the main
characters single mother that's correct
wow this movie is good in this I I I
think the game will make money but it's
going to be for its online components I
don't think people are going to care for
the story definitely it was a good
episode check it out I was on there as
well nice all right get off my lawn says
I see that subverse scnr is up and
running again it's still part of timcast
media scanner is its own company it is
not a part of uh timcast it's it was
separate it was started a long time ago
and after some legal issues that were
resolved it is now back and uh you
should definitely check out Shane's
article uh What's the title of it the
demon Hunters the demon Hunters yeah it
is uh it is about men who run sting
operations tracking child abusers child
predators and gets them arrested yep
yeah you know every state is different
has different laws and what you can do
as a civilian to get someone arrested
for these crimes and in Ohio they have
to be in possession of the uh the bad
stuff uh and they were to a few of these
guys and the cops came came and we got
them arrested and it was beautiful and
they do it all the time they travel the
whole country Matthew Ammon says why has
the day uh why is the daily wire not
spun off its movie division into a
separate company have theatrical
releases followed by video on demand and
streaming info on DW plus you are not
reaching non DW
members yeah I mean that's true but it's
also self-reinforcing that's like I mean
Netflix doesn't reach non- Netflix
members but we don't care because they
have 200 million members right but they
have 200 million members because of
exclusivity which over time drove large
subscription basis so there's you know
it's it's a challenge listen business
models shift and change uh we we
obviously with what is a woman just as
an example found a way to have it be
exclusive for a period and then we put
it out for free on X and it became one
of the most viewed documentaries
probably of all time so to say that
we're only meet only reaching our
members I don't think that's true I
think it's true to say that we only
reach our members when we only reach our
members um but will we eventually break
out uh into theatrical and other things
I think we will but you have to be
honest too there is no world where this
film could have ever come out in
theaters there's what what is Angel
Studios uh they use that um what is it
called fathom I think it was and I don't
I don't even think they would no they
would not they they I'm sorry they'd be
like Angel Studios has a movie coming
out in theaters on Friday Friday shift
called the shift yeah which was produced
by a buddy of mine and and they're doing
great with that model I'm I'm very
interested in putting some of our stuff
in theaters but again do you you think
that anybody's going to you couldn't
this is a true story every time we
release a movie we've been covered by
the Hollywood trades deadline Hollywood
Reporter Etc they won't even write about
the fact that we made lady Ballers well
out outed you think theaters are going
to actually take this movie they'll get
uh I think it's time for Jeremy's Cinema
there you go there you go it's just like
every time they say no I mean have you
publicly told the story of together
again no should you I know if you're
allowed to well I mean I'm allowed to if
you want to so you I mean people may not
know that uh I was in one of the most
successful bands of all time yes from
from the 1950s through today uh Smoky
Mike and the god king and two years ago
daily wire was putting on a show at the
Ryman Auditorium you know it's the it's
one of the most famous music venues in
the
world so it seemed to me that if we were
going to do a show there we should
perform a song you gota if you're can't
just get up there and talk politics at
the Ryman you got to sing and so I had
this fun idea that we should do the song
by the turtles called together again no
happy together I'm sorry called happy
together well I it's a awesome song
nobody's ever been unhappy listening to
happy together and I had this funny idea
that that Smoky Mike Michael nolles and
I could play every instrument as we had
done the year previous in our music
video we we did a cover of the of the
Charles Brown song Please Come Home for
Christmas and played all the instruments
and it was a lot of fun so I thought
well we'll play every instrument and the
end of happy together is I me a lot
going on I thought it'd be fun we'll be
playing trumpets and trombones and drums
and we'll be get a big LED screen up
there and it'll be us playing being
accompanied by us I had a whole vision
for it so I reached out to my team and I
said you know go get me the rights they
they talked to the guys at the Rhyman
you what's it usually cost to get the
rides for a onetime live produ live
performance of a song at the
Ryman you you have to know because for
live performances and video you have to
get sign off if you're just going to
record audio of someone's song you don't
have to get any sign off right that's a
mechanical royalty but for for live
performances and and video there's a a a
form this it's usually 1,500 bucks you
know so we we reached out to the
Publishers for the turtles and we
offered them 1500 bucks to let us
do uh happy together and they came back
and said no well I was pretty surprised
by that so I called A buddy of mine
who's a multi-g Grammy award-winning
songwriter and I said Hey listen here's
what
happened they they said no and he said I
didn't even really I've never fully
realized that we could say no he said
you know just basically once a month my
publisher sends me a stack of papers I
sign them and then I collect my money
like that's just it's very uh you know
pruner so I go back to my team and I
said listen this something doesn't smell
right here this is a weird thing let's
offer them
$115,000 and my my GC was like are you
at that's that's 10 times more than they
told us is the going rate I said yeah
but it's I want to know offer him
$115,000 go back to the publisher for
the turtles offer him $155,000 to come
back with a no the next day like don't
even wait they don't even think about it
no I said all right offer him
$150,000 oh my goodness said are you out
of your mind to to perform a song one
single time on stage at the Ryman
$150,000 I said I'm like bro do you even
own a shampoo company like you even own
a razor company of course go offer him
$150,000 so we offer them $150,000 they
turn us down flat wow uh that's crazy
what one thinks that perhaps it has
something to do with us being us right
they must be doing really well yeah oh
yeah the turtles are lousy with $150,000
offers like for one night performances
so I'm pretty dispirited and you know
we've burned up a lot of time with this
now the show is is only a week away and
I'd basically given up on it and I'm in
the shower and I just had this idea for
a song kind of in the vein of Good
Vibrations Happy Together uh Mr Blue Sky
that that sort of tune for a song and
and it's called together again and I I
came to the office where I have a
keyboard set up at my office and I very
quickly scratched it out and I brought
Smokey mic in the office I said I think
we could pull this off he's like we have
less than one week and we did it we we
spent the 150,000 not on licensing uh
happy together but on creating this
video at the last minute I mean people
were literally up around the clock
producing this video we were
soundchecking on stage at the Ryman and
we didn't have the finished video yet
wow 4 hours before the show then the
show gets there uh intermission comes
along people come back from intermission
Thunder crackles through the Ryman and
this the the stage comes to life and we
Smoky Mike and the god king made their
reunion performance and I got the exact
reaction that I wanted which was I could
see the people kind of still in the
faint light of the front row going what
the are they kidding is this real is
this serious which to me is always the
funniest joke as I say in my razor
commercial uh just because it's a joke
doesn't mean it isn't real that's kind
of my approach to I was at that show it
was a you yeah oh wow you you get to see
it live that's amazing it actually is a
really good song somebody should cover
it one of these days I think I think
it's got well so uh we should probably
announce it too because it's two weeks
out but uh we'll I'll keep it relatively
vague uh Carter and I mostly Carter
Banks the Delta production we have a
modern cover of uh Smoky mik and the god
king together again and my basic idea
was not to dis similar to The Experience
you had with them telling you no despite
you offering lots of money the the
strangle hold the the the woke
institutions have on these industries
I'm like we need a double F you I want
to do this thing so that'll be in a
couple weeks but we'll have more
information later we we wrapped the
music video on it we're basically making
fun of modern pop we made a mo modern
synth pop version when it comes out I
ask everyone listening to please tag
Anthony fantano in that video my least
favorite person in music criticism but
so this will be fun but uh let's uh
let's uh we'll read some more read some
more Super
chats Let's uh let's I want try to grab
a good one uh let's see a lot of people
talking about me being on pop culture
crisis that's fantastic villainous V
says Tim the woke lefties and Disney are
more like those kids who have a PS4 but
then get a PS5 and tell their parents oh
yeah why don't I just give the PS4 to
their friends while the parents get
screwed what does that mean I didn't
track it yeah me neither track
it all right the dude toide says here in
Illinois they tried asking surrounding
towns throughout the state to take the
migrants in an effort to clean up
Chicago assuming they're building large
migrant camps must mean they weren't
successful Illinois is tired of Chicago
oh yeah yeah it was pretty wild too the
the aldermen are livid the way the city
is being run during the sub Summer of
Love riots the city diverted the rots
into the neighborhoods by raising the
bridges right sacrificing the residents
for the financial and and Market
districts medieval yeah it's so
hilarious man good Lord the Dude abides
asks Jeremy is Matt Walsh going to be
the grumpy
dwarf well now he
is well yeah so uh uh lady Ballers has
basically like the whole daily wire crew
in it oh yeah does is Snow White in
their movies going to be utilizing well
Snow White you we have announced that
our own Brett Cooper will play the
titular character and as to who else
will be in it I think you know we'll
we'll solve that as we go but on lady
ballers in particular we went out to a
lot of actors and they all told us no
they said no oh yeah and I don't just
mean that we went out to like you know
the kind of actors who would say no we
went out to actors who are conservative
we went out to actors who've told us in
the past we'd walk across glass to be in
a movie with you please put us in your
next daily wire movie we went out to
actors who have already been canceled
wow and it's not as though they read the
script and didn't like it and then said
no many of them on the phone hey you
want to do a movie 100% what's it about
it's about this rag tag bunch of High
School uh former high school basketball
players who realize that they can
Embrace modern gender Theory and compete
as
women you know you that's crazy because
of course they
can't which is why when people say Hey
what if you put this in theaters of of
course you can't put this this movie in
theaters there's there this is this is
the third rail for the left this is
their most religious issue this is the
thing they care about the most because
it's the ultimate attack on reality
itself which is the the necessary
precondition to their Utopia coming to
pass would be a great Wicked Queen she
would be I think I'm gonna buy a theater
oh that's a great idea I don't think
we'll be able to do big Blockbuster
releases but we will be able to have
consistently in rotation movies from you
guys and from Angel Studios and whatever
love it and it would just be a small
local thing I don't think we'd break the
bank with it but we got to build these
physical spaces and have these
opportunities right you know over the
holiday weekend I was like we should go
see a movie I don't know what we're
bored what are we going to do what did
we do we played poker cuz there's
nothing to do and but it was fun it was
fun we had a blast it really is fun
social activity we were looking up
movies and it's like wish and I'm just
like there's nothing there's nothing i'
i' I'd love take a Friday night we are
going to see shift on on Friday so we're
excited for that and then of course very
easily we just have to log in dw+ to
watch lady Ballers so that's that's
rather simple for us and then uh oh this
is cool Friday's going to be wild we uh
we're going to we're going to go see
shift we're going to be hanging out on
the culture war with Tyler Fischer who's
in lady Ballers that's right and he's a
very funny guy and we have the defiant
coming to IRL and they're going to be
playing live in our new musical setup so
it's just really really fun stuff but
let's uh we'll will you have a will you
have a disco ball by Friday no but we
could you really ought to work on that
Tim
yeah uh we have a crazy I guess it's
cool if you don't the new the new the
new facility that we're building is
going to be the most ridiculous thing
ever I I I have no idea what I'm doing
I'm spending millions of dollars is
insane it's we're we're building one of
the biggest private skate facilities for
this new show we've got plans for this
crazy uh um shipping container music
studio it's a it's a 40ft tall building
with a three story structure inside of
it like mentioned that to me before the
show but I don't I understand what
you're describing but I don't understand
why why why build a building in the
building what's what's the advantage so
you have you have a steel building that
is uh 38 ft by 8 in uh 38 uh 8 tall in
the
center inside of it it's insulated
climate controlled you could all the
ceiling we're going to have uh we're
building a skate park inside that also
is designed to function as a stage in
the corner where the bowl section is so
there can be live performances of
standup and music We Are going to have
on one wall movie theater length
projection screen massive and a massive
hanging projector then in the back you
have a 25 by um 75 structure first floor
is a kitchen and a recording studio
second floor is uh Bar Lounge and IRL
studio and third floor is going to be
Lounge movie theater and so uh the point
is uh morning like we're we're doing a
variety of shows on the first floor IRL
on the second floor the kitchen will be
potentially for probably just for you
know you're getting your drinks you're
getting your maybe outside to the left
is going to be a uh $500,000 concrete
skate park wow and inside is going to be
probably A200 or $300,000 concrete skate
uh not concrete a wooden skate park so
it can be a bit more modular we can
change it and this is for our Massive
Action Sports uh program that we're
launching we're working with Richie
Jackson one of the best Pros ever he's a
street magician and we've got a bunch of
other people involved we're launching a
board company and and and a line of
products so the point is like I'm a
skateboarder when the wokeness started
coming and attacking something that I
cared about I just launched every
nuclear weapon that we had at it and
said no way not happening I Never filmed
skateboarding I always minded my
business and then only recently I
started filming and you know I'm putting
out clips that are getting a decent
amount of attention because people were
like I didn't real Iz Tim was actually
this good at skateboarding and in fact
I'm particularly good so I always just
kind of wanted to mind my own business
and say I don't care you do whatever you
want but now they really are insulting
and attacking skateboarding and I'll
tell you what I went to go uh skate and
DC and for no reason I start getting
attacked by these local skate companies
these these team Riders they start
insulting me and posting online in
various forums lying about my
capabilities and I'm like like this has
gone too far I will mind my own business
but you go online and attack me for no
reason when I said nothing to you and
then lie and claim I can't skate they
said in these forums Tim poool can't do
pop shets which is like for those I
don't know pop shoveit is one of the
first things that kid learns it's where
the board spins one time and so I have a
trick that I put up that's got 600,000
views on Instagram and it's getting a
bunch of attention because it's a
ridiculous trick well beyond the
capabilities of any of these people and
that pissed me off when I'm when I'm
seeing the action to Wess invading these
Sports especially you we're good friends
with Taylor Silverman she works works
with us and she is a female
skateboarding athlete who lost money to
male competitors yeah and when she said
like what's going on what really
bothered me were were all of these
industry heads who are like we
completely agree with you this stuff's
wrong but we won't say anything and then
I'm like I will I'm going to say it as
loud as I can and then when these woke
people try insulting me they write you
know we did a culture War episode with
Richie Jackson and Taylor and uh Dennis
our filmer and when they start insulting
saying ha Tim pool blah blah blah I'm
like listen buddy we've got a
multi-million dollar skate facility
we're building big parks and we're
inviting Pros out and the pros have
already come and filmed with us we're
leaving you behind your crackpot
far-left garbage will have nothing to do
with the things that we love and care
about and we're already winning and one
day you will wake up in the corner
crying to yourself because you are not
going to be able to hang out cuz you're
the weirdo but I'll tell you what you
drop all that weirdness I don't care
what you believe come skate you want to
be weird and a weird activist not
skating with us exactly anyway that's
that's that's that's my my my passion
and my rage right now so here I am at 37
almost 38 and I'm like time to get back
in shape and get back to the crazy
tricks I used to do when I was 19 so I
can reinforce and kick these people out
I I look I've got pro skateboarders who
have hit me up voted for Trump prominent
28-year-old well-known six figure income
not the biggest skateboarders in the
world and they're like but I can't say
anything dude like I'll get my sponsors
dropped and I'm like I am sick of that
yeah you just I get it but so so my
answer was simply this I talked to these
big companies and I said I'll tell you
what I'm going to do when you tell your
writers not to say these things because
get kicked off the team I'm going to
give your writer double what you were
paying them then they can say whatever
they want MH and they're like a couple
of them were like yes cuz I I only like
associate with the ones who are like
let's do it man and they're more cool
about it all right here we go golden
fleece game says referring to your
France segments from earlier the city of
Leon is pronounced Leon not lion yes I
learned that after I'm not I'm not from
France you know uh Greg duvier says
Jeremy's Silent Night dark chocolate is
amazing is that something you have hey
thank you yeah we just released our dark
chocolate and a milk chocolate with
peppermint for Christmas that sounds
great l order we actually have a whole
bunch still here we have a we ordered
large amounts of Jeremy's chocolate nuts
and nutless yep and and uh everybody
preferred the without nuts I sure did
yeah like like but I don't like nuts in
my chocolate just as a rule I'm allergic
to almonds what well that that
hurts I'm as a somewhat famous chocolate
here I know it's somewhat uh
counterproductive but I actually so
prefer dark chocolate to milk chocolate
agreed so I'm I'm very happy to finally
have a great dark chocolate out and
before I left the country 6 months ago a
big part of what we were doing was taste
testing and refining and making notes
and I think we came up with a really a
really good recipe so I'm glad people
are getting to experience it now let's
get a couple more in here uh Ian Slater
says Jeremy where can actors submit head
shots and rums for future movie projects
yeah uh our producer on most of these
projects is Dallas son from bonfire
Legend he he's been working with us
since we first got into doing features
uh and and he's an he's very accessible
if you reach out to Dallas online you'll
almost certainly get a response from him
he's on Twitter as bonfire Legend on
Instagram as bonfire legend that is
always the best place uh you know daily
wire proper is a hard place to submit
for all kinds of reasons you know there
there's a lot of legal restrictions I
can't even open emails anymore right
because you just you you put yourself in
positions of high liability but Dallas
is a great a great first try and we're
you know we're always looking for new
Talent yeah I was I was saying um it
would be great to see Ian get involved
in some projects but as long as his
character is going to be a Christian
conservative suit wearing button- down
type he can't be a like it it has to be
that yeah I would like to see that yes
uh let's see we'll we'll grab one more
Paul tascos says Jeremy I want a private
jet charter company called Vault
Aviation I'll happily sell you the
company so you can Rebrand it the daily
flyer no better way to troll the climate
cult than getting into carbon creation
culture I mean that's pretty great idea
I love it who who doesn't want Jeremy's
Airlines oh man I mean that's the joke
it's like idiocracy everything was
Costco what's going to happen with the
culture war is just this would be a
great skit by the way maybe you guys
should do it where it's you know slowly
over time it's a narration of Jeremy
just kept launching companies after
every other company abandoned its
principles and then it ends with you as
an old man and you're like sitting on a
throne of gold and you just everything
in the United States is Jeremy the roads
have your name on it the toll toll
booths you just bought it all I mean
basic you basically just took my entire
vision for my life and reduced it to a
skit all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.net
a face shave it with Jeremy's razors
when we when we finally do get our
coffee shop open what we wanted to do
was Saturday morning cartoons was the
event we call it yeah the idea is to
have families come with catered food
bring their kids and the TVs will play
approved familyfriendly kids content and
I would love to have beny when we get to
that point I know where you can find
some absolutely I got two things please
go and read the demon Hunters it's one
of the most important stories I've ever
written and uh support Alex in his work
uh that's at scanner.com
sr.com and the second thing is uh you
and I a lot about synchronicities and
weird things that match up and today is
actually the year anniversary of Kanye
West coming here which is the day I met
him it's the anniversary of uh who is
they though who is they and uh that
story I wrote that weekend changed my
life forever and opened up a lot of new
opportunity so thank you for that and
thanks to yay and here to Livy I'm it's
such an honor that who is they though is
was born out of they said that right was
born out of this weird moment we had
beautiful wonderful time it's been a
crazy year uh I'm Libby Emmons I would
like to shout out the post
millennial.age docomo the internet as
surge.com please argue with me on Twix I
do enjoy it uh yeah let's get to the
after show Tim we'll see you all over at
timcast.net